you said that the liver does
uh quite a few things
uh what do you use fascinating beautiful
about the liver i would say its primary
function seems to be as the sort of
gatekeeper for what we eat and absorb
you know the entire gastrointestinal
tract from the esophagus to the rectum
the blood flows from it not back to the
heart but to the liver where it's first
examined kind of things are evaluated
packaged uh you know processed
detoxified perhaps
and it's kind of this great overseer of
what we digest and absorb
and so it kind of keeps
keeps track of of what's coming in you
know the outside world that comes in and
become will become part of us you know
why that's why partly the liver suffers
sometimes the injury from
uh certain certain toxins like alcohol
but beyond that the liver is also the
place as i said it metabolizes things
too so it metabolizes alcohol and why it
can be injured by alcohol it metabolizes
drugs like tylenol which is why
tylenols uh can be very toxic to the
liver when taking them as an overdose
so the liver you know even beyond that
the liver produces a lot of different uh
you know things that float in the
bloodstream it packages uh cholesterol
and fats and sends them to where they're
needed it deals with protein in the
blood it deals with clotting factors in
the blood helping the blood clot
um you know
processes things like bilirubin and
other things that really as i mentioned
there's like 15 organs wrapped into one
maybe that's why it's sort of the
biggest internal organ the skin's bigger
but it's not an internal organ
right the biggest
organ in the human body is the skin
right
but the liver is the biggest internal
organ and it really is a powerhouse and
and does a lot which is why when people
suffer from liver failure kind of
everything goes wrong in a way
you